first up he is the former FBI Special
Agent author of messin with the enemy
surviving in a social media world of
hackers terrorists Russians and fake
news [ __ ] watts
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you all right so listen in light
of this shooting we don't know a lot
about it but it is of course involved
with social media everything is and your
book is a lot about that you have
something a phrase I thought was very
interesting clickbait populism you think
this applies here would you tell us what
that is it does you know we could not
have Donald Trump as president before
the era of social media and there are
audiences that have powered him what
he's been able to do and what other
leaders like the leader of the Islamic
state have been able to do is use social
media to power their agenda and win a
crowd leaders aren't born anymore
they're accrued through retweets likes
and shares and what we're seeing today
our audience has taken on the tactics
the same tax that we saw of the Russians
and using it for their own partisan
purposes we don't really need to worry
about the Russians at this point because
everybody's copy in that playbook yeah I
saw that within 20 minutes of this
shooting there was fake information
about the shooter the right wing is
always trying to make these people into
leftists oh they faked him with a
Hillary hat on right with it and people
don't really check this stuff out they
are going to sites first of all that
confirm what they want to believe to
begin with right right this is all about
confirmation bias and implicit bias
confirmation biases I only pick that
what I want to hear implicit bias is if
it comes from my friends family or
people that look like me and talk like
me then I will take it on and believe it
to be true and no one can shout that
down so the first thing you see is what
you tend to believe is true and that
which you see the most often and that's
why this social media misinformation we
sell like today can mislead people
defame people it can ruin people's lives
and yet none of it is true and it's very
hard to correct that falsehood this
this shooter had two subjects on his
Instagram account
guns and Trump I don't know what that
means but I don't think it's good no I
mean what we've seen across all of this
populism whether it's jihadi populism we
used to talk about with Isis Islamic
state or with the extremist groups in
the United States its violence and it's
a promotion of violence and we've got
easy access to weapons
we've got unlimited access to social
media very easy ability to make content
it's it's a dangerous mess and just the
way they micro target for selling
products they do it with people's
opinions too I know you've said that
Alex Jones your example is perfect for
for what Russia is doing because he will
lead them right to the gullible idiots
that's right people you know that are
falling for this oftentimes are new to
these information sources they don't
really know how to evaluate them they're
new to social media and they're hyper
partisan they really want to be part of
what I call a social media nation and
the more time people spend on cell
phones and with their virtual friends
the more connected they come with them
and that starts to overtake literally
Trump physical nations those people that
live around them like Americans so you
start to identify not by you know the
American flag or a common beliefs and
values and democracy but hashtags
avatars BIOS and pictures if you want to
know who an Isis supporter is that's
easy go look for bin Laden pictures
awful cute pictures Baghdady pictures
and Isis flags if you want to know who a
trump supporter is well that's May Magga
hats Magga Trump train and you know a
handful of other hashtags and the next
one that come up is the resistance I
mean if you want to understand how Trump
overtook the GOP it's the same way isis
overtook al qaeda and how the resistance
could overtake the democrats that's the
next real social media bubble that's
coming up what do you mean the
resistance could overtake you mean I
thought the resistance was the Democrats
Jesus it's worse than I thought well
it's true I mean what do you mean are
they different it's that you can
understand there's more of an identity
attached to those social media
nationalism then there is to these
actual traditional organizations so al
Qaeda used to
how do we know these people are in
al-qaeda where GOP says we don't
actually believe in these things Trump's
supporters say and now we have the
resistance which oftentimes is that you
know battles with traditional Democrats
and in the end the mainstream left so as
a longtime FBI man what do you think
this week when Trump says there was a
mole from the FBI in my campaign FBI
doesn't do moles and campaigns do they
know it's a bunch of nonsense and I mean
it's you know we I've been saying that
the Russians the Russians don't need to
make fake news because the president
makes plenty for them to use and so the
new threat really is that we have
American active measures we have
Americans that are destroying US
institutions with complete falsehoods
the FBI's mission is to protect the
United States so if they had tips that
there might be a Russian infiltration
into the United States to meddle with
our election which has been found out
then they should go after that so using
a confidential informant a trusted
source to go test out those leads it
would be negligent for them not to do
that and they were doing what they
should be doing protecting our economy
it's amazing
isn't how quickly it has turned around
about the FBI I mean I was freaking out
when Trump won the election because at
that moment I thought the FBI was in his
pocket they were calling the FBI trouble
and eeeh yeah remember that trump bill
and you're explaining right they were
saying that Comey released that letter
eleven days before the election that
sunk Hillary because he was losing
control of the FBI and he had to do that
from pressure within his own
organization I don't know if that's true
right but how did the FBI completely
turn around this is so scary that they
are so quickly able to change people's
minds on a fundamental matter like who's
with the who is the FBI with yeah it's
interesting that the president likes to
pick on people that can't fight back
namely the intelligence community and
the FBI can't come out and defend
themselves who can't
well the Muller investigation can but
they're gonna do things properly right
they're gonna go through sources they're
gonna go through methods and
traditionally from what I remember it's
a very conservative organization I
remember going to the seventh I remember
going to the seventh floor of the FBI
headquarters with a green shirt one day
and they were like white or blue here
yeah no green what are you doing
yes I've always been a big fan of
squares yeah squares keep society going
that's right in ways I could not that
that might be true yeah it is very true
I'm not the hunter I'm drawing on the
cave of the wall but that's not
essential what you did was much more
essential what what do you think about
Rudy Giuliani
saying a guy just threw up at the name
of I heard a man literally throw up in
his mouth
right am i right okay and you are
correct sir by the way but him saying
that you can get information from a
foreign government and that's perfectly
legal he said you know when Iran people
tried to get dirt on me it's not nice
but it's the way it is I doesn't matter
if it's a Russian or German that's crazy
- right no America first means Americans
first and you don't take anything from a
foreign country that's trying to destroy
our institutions destroy and put
divisions between our own people so that
they fight each other so that they can
break us up into pieces divide and
conquer us you don't do that and what we
have seen is even in other cases let's
go back to Gore versus Bush there was a
gore staffer who received a playbook
essentially for the debate what did he
do he said I'm turning this over to the
FBI and I'm I will recuse myself from
the debate because I don't want one to
be seen as doing dirty tricks and two I
don't want anyone to think that there
was something up when the debate comes
that was the exact scenario if the
Russians show up at your building called
Trump Tower as Russian government
attorneys the first call you make is the
FBI and the last thing you do is shut
the door and don't let those people in
where you're a real Patriot I hope so
you and I are not sharing a cell so
today
and watch thank you very much sir all
right